supongamos que tenemos la función fx
igual a logaritmo natural de x a la
cuarta más 27 lo que queremos hacer es
tomar su primera y segunda derivada y
usar todas las técnicas que tenemos para
intentar hacer su gráfica si tenemos
tiempo sacar la calculadora gráfica
después para ver qué tanto nuestro
dibujo coincide con el de la calvo una
buena forma de empezar es tomando la
derivada de esto entonces la derivada de
fs efe prima de x y es igual a pues a
ver es la derivada de lo de adentro
entonces la derivada aquí adentro es 4 x
al cubo y luego hay que multiplicar por
la derivada de lo de afuera evaluada en
lo de adentro afuera tenemos logaritmo
natural y su derivada es 1 / x lo de
adentro es x a la cuarta más 27 entonces
nos quedaría x 1 / x a la cuarta más 27
ok si te parece un poco confuso a lo
mejor quieras volver a checar el vídeo
de la regla de la cadena pero bueno esa
es la primera derivada que
escribir así como 4x al cubo entre x a
la cuarta más 27 o bien como 4x al cubo
x x a la cuarta más 27 elevado a la
menos 1
todas estas tres expresiones son iguales
ya se han multiplicado ya sea acá con el
exponente a la menos uno o como fracción
estas tres expresiones son igualitas
vale esa es la primera derivada pasamos
a la segunda la segunda derivada vaya a
esto ya se empieza a ver un poco más
tenebroso bueno va la segunda derivada
es igual a haber entonces ahora podemos
usar la regla del producto era la
derivada del primero multiplicado por el
segundo ok para la derivada del primero
baje el 3 3 por 4 12 12 x al cuadrado
verdad bajamos el exponente 1 x esto
multiplicado por equis a la cuarta más
27 a la menos 1 y luego a eso queremos
sumarle la primera expresión
a ver la pongo con verde 4 x al cubo x
la derivada de la segunda expresión la
derivada de la segunda expresión es otra
regla de la cadena es la derivada de lo
de adentro que simplemente es 4 x al
cubo entonces nos queda por 4 x al cubo
multiplicado por la derivada de lo de
afuera evaluada en lo de adentro
entonces multiplicada por pues aquí es
elevar a la menos 1 bajamos el exponente
x menos 1 y luego esta cosa es x a la
cuarta más 27 y tenemos que elevar al
exponente disminuido en 1 es decir
elevar a la menos 2 entonces déjame ver
tipo simplificar esta expresión un poco
entonces esto es igual a es igual a 12 x
al cuadrado / / x a la cuarta más 27 y
luego tenemos que sumar esta expresión o
más bien como hay un menos restar la
haber 4 x 4 es 16
aquí está 16 x al cubo x x al cubo es x
a lasexta y luego nos queda esta
expresión a la menos 2 entonces podemos
dividir entre x a la cuarta más 27
elevado al cuadrado simplemente lo que
hice fue cambiar un exponente negativo
aquí a un exponente positivo pero
poniéndolo en el denominador no he hecho
hasta aquí nada raro déjame ver si puedo
simplificar un poco más esta fracción
como lo que nos gustaría eventualmente
es igualar esta derivada a 0 para
encontrar puntos críticos entonces sería
útil tener una fracción sólida en vez de
tener una diferencia de fracciones
entonces lo que podemos hacer es pues
pasar todo al denominador común verdad
entonces esto tenemos que multiplicarlo
por x a la cuarta más 27 para hacer
coincidir los denominadores nos queda
haber arriba hay que multiplicar por x a
la cuarta más 27 entonces nos queda 2x
al cuadrado por x a la cuarta más 27 y
luego hay que dividir entre x a la
cuarta más 27 y eso elevado al cuadrado
lo único que hice fue multiplicar el
numerador y denominador por x a la
cuarta más 27 no he cambiado nada luego
hay que restar 16 x a la sexta dividido
entre x a la cuarta más 27 elevado al
cuadrado va entonces ahora ya tenemos un
denominador común y podemos sumar las
fracciones bueno restar las nos queda
igual
a ver hay que multiplicar aquí es todo
déjame poner la rayita de fracción abajo
nos queda x a la cuarta más 27 al
cuadrado esta expresión es el
denominador y en el numerador nos queda
2x al cuadrado por equis a la cuarta que
es 12 x a la 6 y luego hay que hacer un
27 por 2 se me dio un poco de flojera
hacerlo no voy a dejar expresado así lo
voy a poner simplemente como un más 27
por 12 por x al cuadrado verdad aquí
está 2x cuadrada por 27 y luego hay que
restar 16 x a la sexta menos 16 x a la
sexta va entonces esto se va a
simplificar todo ya podemos cancelar
unas cositas por los x a la sexta verdad
entonces nos queda igual y lo voy a
hacer aquí en color rosa nos queda 27 x
12 x cuadrada esto estoy evitando
hacerlo por un momento y luego a ver es
menos 16 x a la sexta más 12 x a la
sexta que nos queda menos 4
por equis a la sexta sale todo eso
dividido entre equis a la cuarta más
veintisiete le pongo por aquí unos
paréntesis y lo elevó al cuadrado listo
con esto encontramos la segunda derivada
muy bien ya encontramos las derivadas y
vaya que fue la pto psoe lo que sigue es
encontrar aquellos puntos para los
cuales se anulan la primera y la segunda
derivada con esto tendremos los puntos
críticos y los candidatos a puntos de
inflexión a lo mejor con eso comenzamos
a ver la luz al final del túnel entonces
empezamos con cuando la derivada se hace
igual a cero o bien cuando la primera
derivada no queda definida ahí podría
haber otro punto crítico entonces esta
expresión esta de aquí es igual a cero
solamente cuando el numerador es igual a
cero el denominador si lo observamos
bien y suponemos que tenemos puros
números reales aquí hay algo positivo
pues es un número elevado al cuadrado
bueno más bien es algo al cuadrado al
cuadrado pero también es positivo y
cuando le sumamos 27 pues siempre queda
mayor o igual que 27 entonces nunca
puede ser negativo ni cero
entonces tampoco pues puede estar no
definido verdad entonces en todos los
puntos la deriva de está definida de
este modo para que la derivada sea igual
a cero necesitamos que 4x al cubo sea
igual a 0 y la única solución de esta
ecuación es para cuando x es igual a 0
haber 4x al cubo es igual a cero implica
que x al cubo es igual a 0 y para que
algo al cubo sea igual a 0 es porque x
es igual a 0
entonces f prima de 0 es igual a 0
va entonces es 0 es un punto crítico
déjame lo escribo por aquí es un punto
crítico la pendiente en cero es cero no
sabemos si es un máximo un mínimo o si
es un punto de inflexión todavía claro
podría ser pues alguna cosa más rara
verdad no ahorita vamos a explorarlo
pero bueno vamos a obtener las
coordenadas las coordenadas son cero
coma y que es logaritmo natural si x es
cero esto es 0 nos queda el logaritmo
natural de 27 déjame está con la
calculadora dijimos que no vamos a usar
una calculadora gráfica todavía pero
esta es una calculadora
a ver logaritmo natural de 27 es tres
puntos pues como 3.3 a ver entonces
déjame copiarlo por aquí voy a ponerle
tres puntos mejoró como 3.29 para hacer
un poco más precisos ok entonces este de
aquí es nuestro punto crítico aquí la
pendiente es igual a cero vale ok
entonces en x igual a cero la pendiente
0 déjame ponerlo aquí en un rectángulo
para acordarnos de eso ahora pasemos a
los candidatos a puntos de inflexión
recuerda necesitamos que la segunda
derivada se anule pero si la segunda
derivada sea nula eso no nos dice que
definitivamente tenemos un punto de
inflexión déjame escribirlo aquí abajo
porque es muy importante esto a ver si x
es un punto de inflexión
entonces la segunda derivada en x es
igual a 0 porque pues ahí tenemos un
cambio en la concavidad de la función
verdad pasamos de que tuviéramos una
concavidad positiva o más bien una
pendiente que iba aumentando a una
pendiente que iba disminuyendo o
viceversa pero si la derivada si la
segunda derivada es igual a 0 no podemos
suponer que es un punto de inflexión
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar todos los candidatos es decir
en donde se cumple esto y ver si
realmente tenemos un cambio de signo en
la derivada en ese punto y solo si
tenemos un cambio de signo podemos
llamarle un punto de inflexión entonces
si simplemente la segunda derivada es
igual a cero eso no quiere decir que
tenemos un punto de inflexión además de
eso necesitamos que haya un cambio en el
signo de la segunda derivada vale no me
canso de decirlo verdad bueno entonces
déjame escribirlo aquí sí
efe doble prima cambia
de signo
x entonces ahí sí podemos decir que x es
un punto de inflexión ahora sí cambia
signos alrededor de x pues claro que la
segunda derivada va a ser igual a 0 pero
bueno hay que ver que antes era negativo
y después era positivo o bien viceversa
entonces vamos a ver si esto pasa la
primera cosa que necesitamos hacer es
encontrar estos puntos candidatos
recuerda los puntos candidatos es donde
se anula la segunda derivada vamos a
encontrar aquellos puntos y vamos a ver
si esto es cierto que el signo cambia
alrededor de ellos entonces queremos
encontrar donde esto es igual a 0 es el
mismo argumento verdad para que todo sea
igual a 0 el numerador debe de ser igual
a cero porque el denominador siempre es
positivo es exactamente el mismo
argumento que habíamos dado arriba
entonces vamos a ver donde el numerador
se hace igual a cero
ok entonces vamos a poner que 27 x 12 x
a la cuarta menos 4 x a la sexta es
igual a cero recuerda esto de aquí es el
numerador de la segunda derivada pero
cualquier x que haga el numerador 0 va a
hacer que la segunda derivada se haga 0
entonces vamos a factorizar un 4x
cuadrada haber 4x cuadrada x 27 por aquí
hay que sacar un 4 entonces nos queda
nada más un 3 y el x cuadrada ya lo
sacamos menos el 4 ya lo sacamos y aquí
nos queda x a la cuarta igual a 0 sale
entonces las x es que hacen esto igual a
cero son ya sea a ver déjame cambiar el
color ya sea 4 x al cuadrado igual a 0 o
bien 27 x 3 a eso sí lo podemos hacer
verdad eso de eso
7 por 3 21 23 por 26 81 81 menos menos x
a la cuarta igual a 0 a ver cualquier x
que satisfaga cualquiera de estos dos va
a ser que la expresión sea igual a cero
si alguna de éstas es cero el producto
es cero y viceversa verdad dijimos que
esto de aquí era 81 ok entonces 4x
cuadrada de cero cuando x es igual a
cero misma idea que arriba verdad
necesitamos que x cuadrada sea igual a
cero y sólo pasa si x es igual a cero
aquí a la derecha necesitamos que x a la
cuarta sea igual a 81 y haber sacamos
raíz cuadrada obtenemos x al cuadrado es
igual a 9 y a partir de esta expresión x
es igual a más menos 3 x + menos no
perdón perdón x es igual a más menos 3
listo entonces estos de aquí son
nuestros candidatos a puntos de
inflexión x igual a 0 x igual a más 3 o
equis igual a menos 3 entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es ver si la segunda
derivada cambia de signo
alrededor de estos puntos esto para
verificar si son puntos de inflexión
o no entonces qué sucede cuando x es un
poquito pero bien poquito más chiquito
que 0 a ver lo voy a hacer por acá
qué pasa cuando x está abajo de cero no
muy muy muy chiquito sino como x igual a
punto uno vamos a ver cuánto es la
segunda derivada ahí si x es igual a
punto 1 entonces a ver si x es menos
punto 1 esto de aquí es positivo verdad
y este término de acá va a ser 81 menos
punto 1 a la cuarta punto 1 a la cuarta
es súper chiquito verdad entonces nos
queda un positivo por 81 menos un número
chiquito entonces es un número positivo
entonces cuando x es menor que cero
bueno un poquito más chiquito que cero
efe doble prima evaluada en x es mayor
que cero ahora qué sucede cuando x es un
poquito más grande cuando escribo esta
anotación
simplemente me estoy refiriendo a que es
esta abajito de cero verdad aquí también
me refiero a que x está arriba de cero
digamos cuando x es igual a punto uno
pues bases más o menos lo mismo verdad
aquí tenemos una potencia 4a
estamos perdiendo realmente la
información de signo entonces si x es
igual a punto 1 esto de aquí es un
número positivo chiquito estamos
restando un número muy chiquito de 81 y
81 menos un número chiquito de todas
formas es como positivo verdades como
80.9 bla bla bla entonces la segunda
derivada también nos queda positiva
fíjate aquí pasa algo interesante en f
es decir la segunda derivada es cero
cuando x es igual a 0 pero no es un
punto de inflexión pues fíjate como la
concavidad de la función no cambia
alrededor de 0 nuestra derivada aquí es
positiva conforme nos acercamos a x por
la izquierda y también es positiva
cuando estamos a la derecha de 0
entonces en general en 0
bueno conforme estamos cerca de 0 en
cualquier dirección tenemos una función
cóncava hacia arriba entonces el hecho
de que 0 sea un punto crítico combinado
con que la pendiente siempre crece nos
lleva a la conclusión de que este punto
de aquí tiene que ser un punto mínimo
aquí escribo
mínimo vale porque pues porque estamos
en cóncavo hacia arriba y cóncava hacia
arriba y punto crítico nos da un mínimo
entonces es cero no es un punto de
inflexión vamos a ver qué pasa con más
menos 3
entonces si estudiamos esta ecuación
déjame escribir
y sabes que déjame aclarar esto sigue
usando el puro numerador de la segunda
derivada porque mira todo esto es la
segunda derivada pero he estado
ignorando el denominador porque el
denominador siempre es positivo entonces
si queremos entender el signo de la
segunda derivada basta entender el signo
del numerador porque el denominador
siempre es positivo cualquier cosa entre
más tiene el mismo signo que la
cualquier cosa entonces pues vamos a ver
si hay un cambio de concavidad alrededor
de x igual a más 3 o menos 3
entonces recuerda déjame escribir por
aquí la segunda derivada f doble primer
x es igual a el numerador es 4x al
cuadrado x 81 menos x a la cuarta y el
denominador lo tengo aquí arriba es x a
la cuarta más 27 al cuadrado lo pongo
aquí x a la cuarta más 27 elevado al
cuadrado vale entonces esa es la segunda
derivada vamos a ver si esto cambia de
signo alrededor de más menos 3
vamos a obtener la misma respuesta en
más y menos tres verdad porque fíjate
que tenemos puras potencias pares eso
nos hace perder la información del signo
entonces basta con checar que pasen más
tres o en menos tres para entender si
realmente tenemos un punto de inflexión
o no cuando hagamos la prueba pues basta
hacerlo para uno de ellos entonces vamos
a intentarlo de todas formas vamos a
hacerlo para cuando x es un poco más
chiquito que 3 y entonces qué pasa con
el signo de esto tenemos 4 por 3 al
cuadrado o sea es 4 por un número
positivo
entonces esto de aquí de todas formas
nos va a quedar positivo aquí nos queda
positivo cuando x se acerca a 3 y de
este lado tenemos pues a ver si x es 3
esto es 0
entonces si x es un poquito más chiquito
entonces nos queda 81 menos algo un poco
más chiquito que 81 de modo que nos
queda pues 81 menos algo más chiquito es
positivo el denominador también es
positivo entonces si x es un poquito más
chiquito que 3 tenemos que la segunda
derivada
es positiva entonces efe doble prima es
mayor que 0 y por tanto las funciones
cóncava hacia arriba
ahora cuando x es un poquito más grande
que 3 vamos a ver qué sucede aquí
tenemos de todas formas una cosa
positiva pero aquí si x es un poquito
más grande que 3x a la cuarta es un
poquito más grande que 81 y entonces
este segundo término es negativo
entonces en esta situación aquí es
negativo
a ver con otro color entonces cuando x
es un poquito más grande esto es más
grande tenemos algo negativo éste es
positivo el producto es negativo el
dividido entre positivo es negativo
bueno espero no haberte hecho bolas pero
el resumen es que la derivada es
negativa y tenemos que la función es
cóncava hacia abajo va vamos a ver qué
pasa cuando x es un poquito más grande
que menos 3 ya sé que ya habíamos
argumentado que iba a pasar lo mismo
pero vamos otra vez a decir cómo va la
cosa a ver aquí tenemos algo negativo
elevado al cuadrado entonces eso se
vuelve positivo aquí tenemos algo
positivo ahora digamos menos 2 puntos 99
a la cuarta es un poquito más chiquito
que 81 pero es algo positivo entonces a
81 le estamos restando pues una cosa más
chiquita que 81 nos queda positivo va
una vez más tenemos cóncavo hacia arriba
y qué sucede finalmente cuando x es un
poco más chiquito que menos 3 es decir
que se está tantito a la izquierda de
menos 3 vale entonces simplemente me
refiero a las x que están pegadas a
menos 3 a la izquierda no a todas las x
es que son menores que menos 3 a lo
mejor debería cambiar de anotación pero
bueno ya ya casi terminamos verdad vale
entonces vamos a ver qué pasa con x
tantito a la izquierda de menos 3
vámonos para acá entonces este término
va a ser positivo pero qué pasa aquí
tenemos menos 3.1 a la cuarta entonces
eso va a ser más grande que 81 porque el
x a la cuarta se vuelve positivo porque
es una potencia para entonces nos queda
negativo entonces en este caso tenemos
más x menos entre más de modo que la
segunda derivada es menor que cero la
función es cóncava hacia abajo
muy bien entonces claro que yo estamos
listos para graficar pero terminamos con
los puntos de inflexión si logramos
conseguir puntos de inflexión pues si
cuando nos acercamos por la izquierda
menos 3 estamos cóncavo hacia arriba
cuando lo cruzamos la segunda derivada a
ella la perdí por acá arriba aquí está
al cruzar 3 la segunda derivada se hace
0 pero luego conforme nos vamos a la
derecha de 3 tenemos que se vuelve
cóncavo hacia abajo entonces hay un
cambio de signo en la segunda derivada y
por tanto 3 es definitivamente un punto
de inflexión lo mismo pasa con menos 3
al atravesarlo la segunda derivada
cambia de signo y por tanto ambos son
puntos de inflexión va vamos a encontrar
sus coordenadas para poder encontrar
estos puntos en el plano ahorita que
grafica hemos es un buen momento para
recapitular los puntos que llevamos
hasta abrir el primero que teníamos era
03.29 ya habíamos dicho que era un punto
mínimo entonces cero era punto crítico
verdad y la pendiente era cero y además
porque ahí es cóncavo hacia arriba
entonces es cero no puede ser un punto
de inflexión
y luego tres y menos tres ya sabemos que
son puntos de inflexión y para encontrar
cuáles son sus coordenadas en y pues
vamos a ver cómo estaba definida a efe a
ver cuando a tener la misma coordenada
en verdad porque más o menos 3 nos va a
dar lo mismo aquí arriba entonces nos
queda 3 a la cuarta es 81 ahora 81 27 es
igual a 108 ya eso le tenemos que sacar
su logaritmo natural
logaritmo natural a esta es 4.68 digamos
que es 4.7 va entonces eso va a pasar
tanto como para 3 y para menos 3 nos
queda 4.7 listo estos de aquí son puntos
de inflexión puntos de inflexión ahora
sí estamos listos para graficar la
función a ver déjame dibujar los ejes
por aquí perdón los ejes por aquí ahí
tenemos el eje x de este lado tenemos el
eje eje x eje y ahí le podemos poner fx
aquí le ponemos x entonces el punto 0,3
punto 29 1 2 3 4 5 bar entonces el punto
03.29 queda como por aquí verdad ahí
tenemos un mínimo de nuestra función y
luego a ver la la pendiente ahí es pero
déjame pintar hay una pendiente igual a
cero fue lo primero que determinamos y
sabemos que las funciones cóncava hacia
arriba entonces
ahí se ve más o menos así y luego
3 1 2 3
aquí tenemos que tomar valor 4.7
entonces es algo de este estilo y
tenemos un punto de inflexión de ahí
antes de eso teníamos que la función era
cóncava hacia arriba y después era
cóncava hacía abajo entonces parece ser
que se va a ver algo así aquí tenemos
cóncavo hacia arriba con forma de y
déjame mejor pintarlo de otra forma creo
que el color amarillo no era el mejor
que podíamos poner déjame ponerle escala
aquí 123 aquí voy a poner el punto 3 4.7
y aquí el menos tres 4.7 algo así
entonces ya sabemos que en cero tenemos
una pendiente igual a cero verdad y
sabemos que va cóncavo hacia arriba
ahora cuando llegamos a este punto a x
igual a 3 tenemos que cambiar la
concavidad se vuelve cóncavo hacia abajo
es decir se vuelve una volteada hacia
abajo a ver lo voy a poner un poco más
como de este estilo para que se vea un
poco más cóncavo hacia abajo y de modo
similar alrededor de cero es cóncavo
arriba hasta que llegamos a x igual a
menos tres moviéndonos a la izquierda y
en x igual a menos 3 cambia la
concavidad voy a hacerlo con
este color el color rosa mexicano vale
entonces este cóncavo hacia abajo lo voy
a pintar con el color rojo para seguir
consistentes con los colores
entonces lo pongo de este color va
entonces ahí está esto de aquí cóncavo
hacia arriba es en este intervalo de por
acá este cóncavo hacia arriba es el de
por acá de verdad vale entonces esto de
aquí es más o menos lo que yo creo que
es la gráfica de la función claro
todavía podríamos ver qué pasa hacia
infinito y menos infinito pero dejémoslo
aquí en vez de esto mejor vamos a
comparar nuestro dibujo con el de la
compu vamos a sacar la calculadora
gráfica a ver cómo se comparan los dos
me traigo para acá el emulador me voy a
aprender y me voy a ir a graficar aquí
tengo que ponerle ye igual a logaritmo
natural de x a la cuarta más 27
entonces ya le voy a aplicar graficar y
ahí está haciendo el dibujito crucemos
los dedos ay qué bien el dibujo de la
cal cv y el nuestro se parecen muchísimo
al parecer las matemáticas que hicimos
las dijimos bien que emocionante vale
espero que tras este vídeo aprecies un
poco más los puntos de inflexión los
puntos críticos y las derivadas y como
éstas ayudan para graficar una función
nos vemos hasta la próxima